Ti insegnerò a proposito di una palla che gira, solo che non è una palla e non sta girando. Oggi in Qiskit in the
Classroom parleremo di questa proprietà quantistica chiamata spin osservando l'esperimento che per primo ne trovò le prove.
Benvenuto a Qiskit in the Classroom. In questa serie useremo Qiskit per esplorare alcuni concetti fondamentali comunemente
trattati nei corsi legati al Quantum Computing. Ogni video sarà accompagnato anche da un modulo interattivo
linkato nella descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di dargli un'occhiata. Oggi parliamo dell'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach del 1922.
È uno dei più famosi nella storia della teoria quantistica perché dimostra in modo così chiaro come funziona lo
spin quantistico. Ma non era quello che Stern o Gerlach intendevano dimostrare. L'esperimento era stato progettato per testare un nuovo modello quantistico
dell'atomo chiamato modello di Bohr, dal nome di Niels Bohr che lo propose nel 1913. Nel modello, gli elettroni orbitavano attorno
al nucleo in orbitali discreti e potevano passare da un orbitale all'altro assorbendo o emettendo
fotoni. Ogni orbitale aveva un momento angolare quantizzato che era un multiplo intero di una piccola costante fondamentale
chiamata ħ. Negli anni 1910 e nei primi anni '20 la meccanica quantistica era nuovissima, così nuova
che non veniva ancora chiamata meccanica quantistica. Quindi non tutti erano convinti del modello di Bohr. Un fisico
di nome Otto Stern lo odiava. Chiamò il modello un'assurdità e arrivò persino a minacciare di abbandonare la fisica se Bohr avesse avuto
ragione. Stern era così determinato a dimostrare che il modello era sbagliato che escogitò un modo ingegnoso per testarlo e
reclutò Walther Gerlach per aiutarlo a progettare e condurre l'esperimento. Si scoprì che non dimostrò che Bohr aveva torto, finì
per dimostrare che aveva torto lui stesso. Il loro esperimento era così semplice e i risultati così netti che praticamente chiusero
il dibattito: la meccanica quantistica governa alla scala atomica. Non se ne resero conto all'epoca,
ma l'esperimento di Stern e Gerlach trovò anche prove conclusive dello spin intrinseco dell'elettrone, che era una
nuova proprietà fondamentale della natura, essenziale per spiegare il magnetismo, la superconduttività e gran parte della
chimica. Oggi ti guiderò attraverso il funzionamento dell'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach, cosa ci aspetteremmo classicamente di vedere
dall'esperimento e cosa Stern e Gerlach finirono per trovare. Poi ti mostrerò come puoi condurre il tuo esperimento
di tipo Stern-Gerlach con Qiskit e un computer quantistico IBM. L'idea di base dell'esperimento di
Stern-Gerlach era trovare un modo per determinare se il momento angolare di un elettrone in un atomo era quantizzato come
Bohr aveva previsto, oppure no, come Stern si aspettava. Sfruttarono il fatto che il momento angolare dell'elettrone avrebbe anche causato la presenza
di un piccolo campo magnetico attorno a ciascun atomo. Quindi puoi pensarli come piccoli magneti a barra.
L'esperimento si presentava così: c'era un forno pieno di atomi
d'argento e un campo magnetico con i poli Nord e Sud
qui. Il campo era più forte vicino alla parte superiore e più debole vicino al fondo, quindi produceva un gradiente diretto verso l'alto.
Infine c'era uno schermo. Nell'esperimento il forno riscaldava gli atomi d'argento fino a farli evaporare e poi
volavano fuori dal forno con l'orientamento del piccolo magnete a barra di ciascun atomo completamente casuale. Poi gli atomi
passavano attraverso il campo magnetico. Gli atomi venivano spinti verso l'alto o verso il basso con una forza che dipendeva dalla direzione del
polo Nord di ciascun atomo rispetto a questo gradiente di campo. Poi gli atomi colpivano lo schermo. Stern e Gerlach potevano guardare
dove gli atomi colpivano lo schermo per apprendere informazioni sul momento angolare degli elettroni. Stern si aspettava che gli atomi
nell'esperimento si comportassero come li ho descritti finora, come piccoli magneti a barra che obbediscono alle
regole della fisica classica. Classicamente, questi piccoli magneti atomici potevano essere orientati in qualsiasi direzione casuale, quindi mentre
attraversavano il campo magnetico potevano subire una gamma di forze diverse che li spingevano verso l'alto o verso il basso a seconda di quegli orientamenti. Un magnete
orientato nella stessa direzione del gradiente subirebbe una grande forza verso l'alto; nella direzione opposta,
subirebbe una grande forza verso il basso; e se fosse in una posizione intermedia, la forza sarebbe più debole. Se il magnete dell'atomo puntasse
perpendicolarmente al gradiente, non subirebbe alcuna forza e continuerebbe dritto. A causa di questa
gamma di forze possibili, gli atomi dovrebbero colpire lo schermo in punti verticali diversi. Il pattern che formerebbero
sullo schermo sarebbe qualcosa del genere. Ma non è tutto quello che Stern e
Gerlach videro. Invece videro due macchie di atomi completamente separate sullo schermo, senza atomi al
centro. Non avevano la teoria corretta all'epoca per spiegarlo, ma ora sappiamo che videro questo perché
ogni elettrone ha una certa quantità di momento angolare intrinseco sotto forma di spin, che può assumere solo uno
di due valori. Nella nostra immagine del magnete a barra, questo significa che ci sono solo due orientamenti permessi dei magneti atomici. Chiamiamo
questi due orientamenti spin up e spin down. Un qubit in un computer quantistico
assomiglia a questo tipo di sistema di spin, e alcuni computer quantistici usano effettivamente qubit fatti dallo spin dell'elettrone.
Quindi possiamo eseguire il nostro esperimento di Stern-Gerlach con Qiskit e i qubit in un computer quantistico IBM. Facciamo
corrispondere lo stato spin up dell'elettrone allo stato zero del qubit e lo stato spin down allo stato uno
del qubit. Quando le particelle d'argento uscivano dal forno avevano momenti magnetici orientati casualmente. Possiamo
modellare l'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach creando un semplice circuit quantistico con un singolo qubit che parte dallo stato
zero. Questo si chiama diagramma del circuit, dove il filo in alto è il qubit e le operazioni applicate al qubit
appaiono come box sul filo. I box RX e RZ sono gate quantistiche che
ruotano effettivamente l'orientamento magnetico dell'atomo. Possiamo scegliere valori casuali di theta e phi qui per ruotare il
qubit di una quantità casuale. Questo imita il forno che sputa gli atomi con orientamenti di spin casuali. Il box grigio è
la nostra misurazione. Ci dice se il qubit è nello stato zero o uno e invia quella misurazione a un bit classico, la
doppia linea etichettata c. Questa parte è equivalente a misurare se l'atomo è in spin up o spin down guardando
quale punto colpisce sullo schermo. Possiamo usare una primitiva di Qiskit chiamata sampler per eseguire l'esperimento molte volte, ciascuna con
valori casuali diversi per theta e phi. Dopo 100 campioni, otteniamo un istogramma delle misurazioni che appare così: circa
il 50% delle volte il qubit viene misurato come zero e il 50% delle volte è nello stato 1. Questo è lo stesso risultato che Stern
e Gerlach videro: è sempre spin up o spin down, mai nel mezzo. A questo punto potresti pensare: beh,
ovvio che abbiamo ottenuto due risultati discreti. Abbiamo eseguito l'esperimento su un computer quantistico digitale che restituisce sempre solo
zero o uno. E questo è vero, ma tieni presente che l'intera ragione per cui i computer quantistici restituiscono risultati binari, anzi
il motivo per cui il Quantum Computing funziona, è proprio questa quantizzazione dello spin che Stern e Gerlach scoprirono per primi.
I qubit nei computer quantistici IBM non sono basati sugli spin, ma molti altri computer quantistici lo sono. Quindi eseguire un
esperimento di Stern-Gerlach su un computer quantistico ci permette di riscoprire effettivamente la quantizzazione dello spin.
Dal 1922, innumerevoli estensioni dell'esperimento originale di Stern-Gerlach sono state eseguite. Queste estensioni prevedono
di inviare lo stesso fascio di atomi attraverso più apparati di Stern-Gerlach per vedere come si comportano gli spin in diversi
scenari. Eccone uno: inviamo gli atomi attraverso un apparato per separare il fascio in due, corrispondenti a un
fascio spin up e un fascio spin down, e poi inviamo ciascuno di quei fasci attraverso il proprio apparato
separato. Con Qiskit, il circuit quantistico corrispondente a questo esperimento è simile all'ultimo ma con due
misurazioni invece di una. Qui abbiamo sostituito le rotazioni casuali che imitavano l'effetto del forno con una
gate chiamata Hadamard, poiché applicare la Hadamard ci darà le stesse probabilità di misurazione del forno
ma è molto più semplice da usare. Quindi misuriamo una volta e poi una seconda volta e
l'istogramma delle misurazioni risultante per l'esperimento appare così, dove le stringhe di bit sull'asse X corrispondono ai
risultati delle due misurazioni. Se il qubit è stato misurato zero entrambe le volte, corrisponde alla stringa di bit 0 0; oppure se
è stato misurato prima zero poi uno, corrisponde a uno zero, e così via. Sembra che se è stato misurato spin up nel
primo esperimento, sarà spin up anche nel secondo. Lo stesso vale per gli atomi spin down. Ciò significa che nel primo esperimento
avevamo uguale probabilità di misurare su o giù, ma al secondo esperimento il risultato era già determinato. Quindi i
due schermi alla fine di ciascuno dei secondi apparati di Stern-Gerlach avrebbero ciascuno una sola macchia. Uno schermo avrebbe
tutti gli atomi spin up e uno schermo avrebbe tutti gli atomi spin down. Per il nostro prossimo esperimento,
partiamo con un fascio di atomi puramente spin up. Con un vero esperimento fisico di Stern-Gerlach potresti farlo inviandoli
attraverso un apparato di Stern-Gerlach e bloccando il fascio deflesso verso il basso. Così tutti gli atomi deflessi verso l'alto sono
spin up. Ora inviamo questo fascio attraverso un altro apparato di Stern-Gerlach, ma stavolta ruotiamo i magneti di 90° in modo che
il gradiente del campo defletta gli atomi che viaggiano in questa direzione verso sinistra o verso destra. Vedremo
una macchia o due, o qualcosa di completamente diverso? Per questo esperimento
eseguiremo il seguente circuit su Qiskit. Partiamo dallo stato zero poiché il nostro fascio di atomi in questo esperimento è tutto
spin up. Poi questa gate Hadamard scambia le coordinate x e z in modo da avere l'effetto di ruotare
l'apparato di Stern-Gerlach, così ora misuriamo la proiezione dello spin a sinistra o a destra invece che su o giù. Qui otteniamo
un istogramma delle misurazioni che appare così. Possiamo vedere che anche lo spin lungo X può assumere solo due valori,
che possiamo chiamare spin sinistro e spin destro. Quindi questo esperimento mostra che se misuri la proiezione X di uno spin
che in precedenza era stato misurato come spin up lungo Z, sarà spin sinistro o destro con uguale probabilità. Confrontiamo
questo un'ultima volta con l'aspettativa classica, giusto per evidenziare davvero la differenza. Classicamente, ricorda che ho
detto che se il piccolo magnete a barra atomico puntava perpendicolarmente al gradiente del campo magnetico dell'apparato,
la forza su quell'atomo dovrebbe essere zero. Non dovrebbe essere deflesso né su né giù. In quel caso vedremmo una singola macchia al
centro dello schermo. Invece vediamo due macchie. Quindi metà degli atomi hanno spin sinistro e metà hanno spin destro, anche
se in precedenza erano stati misurati come spin up. Quindi da una prospettiva di meccanica quantistica, anche se può essere tentante
equiparare spin up con un vettore che punta verso l'alto e spin down con uno che punta verso il basso, non è così semplice, come possiamo vedere
dall'ultimo esperimento. Per capire davvero cosa sta succedendo qui dovremo approfondire i temi della
sovrapposizione quantistica e della misurazione, che saranno argomento di un altro video. Proprio come noi siamo rimasti con più
domande su come funziona esattamente la meccanica quantistica, così furono Stern e Gerlach. Il loro esperimento non spiegò
tutto, ma fece molta strada nello stabilire la meccanica quantistica come essenziale per comprendere il mondo
naturale. Fu uno degli esperimenti fondamentali più importanti nella meccanica quantistica, che dimostrò sia la quantizzazione
del momento angolare sia fornì prove di una nuova proprietà fondamentale della natura chiamata spin. Per confrontarsi davvero con e
comprendere le regole del mondo quantistico, fisici come Stern e Gerlach dovettero sporcarsi le mani progettando
esperimenti, facendo previsioni e a volte sbagliando. Non c'è davvero sostituto al provare le cose da soli,
quindi se vuoi cimentarti nell'eseguire dei veri esperimenti quantistici, vai al modulo di Stern-Gerlach
linkato nella descrizione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.